перемикаємо на ось цю спину
новими квітами 2015 у радж і ставить
крити asus пелена гаманця гендиректор
in the kills виконані оптимізму зураб
Аласа сьогодні серед лиж ним
оптимізму не завершився процес
ліквідації та аудиту всього чарівного
майна віддаси сковороду компанії по всій
україні
ви ви вся здано щось складним латексу
спинному мозку не get out його сама порно
та не your bitch на місцеву
вид пам'ятний закон про гру створ у неї
хвалив і подвір'я до цього
заздрість моя ж 30 національних та
обласних до яких радіокомпанії мало
ніби ст ворони одні великі публічні
акційні товари стовбур з успішним про
війні tube бюрократично звук звалив
замикання за раз чому зад ринку
фіскальна служба у нас злим та зі зручною
праворуч, що означає прихід на радіо над
самим батьківщини була форма колеса земля
наочні ось під від кого підкупу звуки
скажуть ну а кейт робот
оформити цю землю тягнуться над шкірою
кров і уявна нова та ринкові особи
німа та налагодженому фінансово не та tiggo
особистого цей дар стала радіокомпанії
україни виділив із 700 мільйонів гривень
за тигру щи
журналісти мати створ це абсолютно
новий дієвий за лижний формат могла
не про тему з роботою і хоч і калим all
їжу високих рейтингів та застарілу
техніку apple деку та ще з трагічним
персоналом ще далеко
вул і будуть ми протитанковими
провалом купа вперед якомога ближче не ми
зможемо назад без школі у кованих людей
взяти evic сухих dir-100 радіокомпанія
україна була ланка але моя живи 700 с
перу hipster
багата хто судитися з каренством
поклич у майбутнє більше на посилити
бачусь ми можемо зараз нам втб the
radio ресинтез людожер трава скоро
чогось цін можна забути за один раз
не можна за бароном законів зубам
головний державний канал країни задвірок
і ясна пари став ніби рупором влади
шановний експерт тарас Шевченко
алое влада убір гуни заклалося
але вникай просто соботович реформу тієї
факт ще в Україні суспільної блискавка
дасин через проти ла та різак 6 чоловіків
вигляд ніби зі старшого сич на 17 руку на
мою думку суть його завантажу
репутації президента і кай персонально
сказавши що для нього є реформа важливо
першин шукаю давно ви там і ви пробували
трансляція олімпіади в Ріо випадковий
зсув фінансових причин надії slade та
туди своїх корінь вигляду українська влада
ти про закласти я канал пройду доступний
тест євро башта 2017